je vous propose un stage de formation de
six semaines comprenant divers
disciplines le tir à balles réelles
larmes blanches le maniement d'explosifs
les dix-sept méthodes de strangulation
et les empoisonnements naître un vrai
hélas durant ce stage bénéficier d'une
couverture sociale
mais vous avez chic et bénéficierez par
contre d'une carte orange
trois zones si votre travail me donne
satisfaction vous exécuterez votre
premier contrat soit surveillance et si
ce dernier tests s'avèrent probants
je vous engage ray pour une durée de
quatorze années au terme desquels je
vous aiderai ma place mon matériel et ma
fille quand elle le rapport second front
mon attitude de sera sévère mais
nous on est pourvue à l'occasion d'une
certaine affection elles sont nous
sommes en retard ou va dans une maison
de retraite on va tout modifier pour nom
c'est hélas plus compliqué que ça